got a little post game yakity Yak on
this one
oh no
Brooks
Brook discussing the podcast
that's what I do I talk and you know I
told him I told I told him that um you
know keep that mic keep that mic he's
better at the mic then pooping you know
what I'm saying so keep doing this
podcast keep blogging keep doing this
thing off the court you know it's cute
it's fun I get technical Falls when I
want to get the technical file I don't
get baited into technical for Ops
so I think that's probably the
difference in between me and him why
don't you consider this a rivalry
because you have to like one team has to
win and then another team has to win
then like that's what creates a rivalry
and clearly we won four times and I
think that organization has zero
championships so I can't consider that a
rivalry anybody can win in March
anybody can win at March
what that mean
I have a hard time getting out of my bed
in March
the house came in March me
laughs
I love all the smoke man it is this is
this is part of the uh the entertaining
thing about the budding rivalries uh in
the NBA teams that have a little have a
little something going on between them
we love it though this is what it's
about especially this time of year like
Memphis is chasing Golden State Golden
State may not say yeah they're chasing
us but they know they're there they have
their attention and the fact they don't
like each other I hope they see each
other in the playoffs and for me I like
the fact that God says I just don't like
that dude like that's so that's fine I
mean uh it's competition you know Reggie
says something great I don't think
either one of them have crossed the line
I mean when you're talking on podcasts
and things like that or doing sit down
interviews that you can say what you
want to about people but you still have
to have professional respect for each
other and to me even that was a chance
tonight but see Draymond got to be
careful though because they're in a very
serious situation and his next tech is a
suspension and then you out and then
then when you get two you get another if
you get two more you get another
suspense I mean so it's a long way to go
well he and Dylan Brooks are number one
and two yeah but but listen man Luke is
up there too Memphis is going to beat
they they're pretty sure the Warriors
screw around and lose a couple more
games they can be in that playing
situation one is not a rivalry Memphis
is not there yet and when you're the
Champs we got a lot of young teams that
want to take your position well doesn't
it depend on what you consider a rivalry
does it always have to be you haven't
beaten us but when two teams have that
kind of stuff going on then what do you
call that it just stays in the category
that two teams don't like each other
okay I got just about to Memphis having
a good year but they're not good enough
for it to be a robber so it's obviously
two teams that don't like each other I
like all the back and forth and it was a
great game tonight you know they came
played inspired basketball they got a
lot going on they played Focus I noticed
that when the ball is moving and
everybody get a chance to shine and when
they stepping them on defense they look
pretty good so even though John's going
to be out four or five or even more
games I'm not really worried about
Memphis and I like the uh Brooks kid it
reminds me of Rick Fox Rick Fox was God
he's that pretty
without Brandon Clark without Stephen
Adams this is why
you you don't take the NBA for granted
you look at Kevin Durant and Kyrie
Irving
like four years ago we're like this team
probably
go wins him four years are gone
now you go to Memphis
they were like the two seed
a month ago
and now you got the job situation that's
different but now your loss Adams and
Clark
so this pretty much kills your season
this year not yet oh no they're not
going to win the championship without
Clark and Adams they're not and John's
going to come back but without going to
win the championship anyway yeah but
they had a really good chance with Adams
and Clark they were really good but now
this year that's why I tell these guys
man when you have a legit team you
cannot be screwing around because you
don't have a chance to win every year
that's one of the biggest lies ever told
like I always knew I said we got a
chance this year I said yeah we're gonna
try hard and everything but they had a
legitimate chance to do some damage and
now for my opinion it's over for them